these people are all bananas and now  here's the warning connor do we have the  warning for the people yes sir what  you're about to see here is pure  [ __ ] we're about to show you a clip  from the harpies at the view  i have many conservative values that i  will talk to you about and so if you  look at your network that you're  standing behind yes and when you look at  your network that you're standing behind  you're saying that you look at chris  that's the oxymoron a black republican  you feel like it's an oxymoron i do stop  it  get some help why your friend right here  is a republican  you do what you say you feel like it's  obviously more that you're a catholic  but you also have a whole life  i don't understand i know you don't  understand yourself then you have this i  understand myself i don't understand  either of this but is that  the idea that your skin color means that  you have to be part of a political party  man they are the bigots they are the  racists understand it